[Musique]
oui mais menée par le dr cissé melissa
maulin dupuis pour mon petit finale de
2020 ma dernière chronique pour l'année
une année qu'on pouvait je pourrais de
désigner comme annus horribilis ou année
horrible pour faire un bilan je dirais
des choses horribles saison passée cette
année mais on a commencé l'année 2020
avec la crise oui dessous et n est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas pu voir venir c'est
que non seulement les voies ferrées à
l'aide bloqué mais l'ensemble du canada
sauf que pour cet enjeu la vie on parle
aux aides des droits ancestraux des
droits de ne pas voir des projets passés
sur des territoires qui sont gérés par
les communautés autochtones ensuite au
fond bien sûr la crise du couvent est
d'amener tellement d'enjeux a montré la
fragilité
je demandais communauté quand il n'ya
pas accessibilité à de l'eau potable
quand on parle d'une crise entre qu'on
peut même pas avoir de l'eau potable
pour soi nettoyer les mains et nettoyer
les surfaces garantir une certaine
sécurité au niveau de l'eau potable dans
une communauté fermée à cause des fils
du corps il ensuite on a eu beaucoup
d'enjeux aussi par rapport aux identité
autochtone
les nouveaux autochtone une nouvelle
communauté discret qui vont à l'encontre
de certaines des communautés ancestrale
communautés qui sont bien établis au
québec au canada ces discussions là sont
mis de l'avant et montre quand même qu'à
une grande gare aux deux caisses qui
fait de toi un autochtone qu'est ce qui
vient du système comme la loi sur les
indiens
qu'est-ce qui est une identité
administratives par exemple et tout
l'imbroglio qui vient autour de ça de ce
concept là d'être autochtone qu'est ce
que c'est au canada ce qui compliquait
puisqu'on n'a pas les mêmes genres de
manière identique aux états unis par
exemple ou dans le reste de la planète
qu'on est une communauté d'acteurs et
que c'est pas toutes les communautés qui
ont la loi sur les indiens au dessus de
leur tête
ensuite on a eu une problématique autour
de la confiance est justement en 2006 on
n'a jamais eu autant besoin d'avoir
confiance envers le système de santé
bien la crise autour de 17 du récit
chaque one continue de toucher les cas
des communautés on essaie encore
aujourd'hui d'avoir une réponse claire
et précise
et ça ça se fait en même temps qu'on est
en train d'avoir un débat de société
avec les personnes au pouvoir sur le
racisme systémique et à voir où en
position pouvoir un parti politique qui
ne veut pas nommer le racisme systémique
mais qui met en place quand même des
pratiques pour combattre le racisme
systémique
c'est un petit peu astérix et la maison
des fous ou même c'est ce qu'on appelle
le gas lighting ce à dire que non c'est
pas vrai ça n'existe pas mais de montrer
le contraire donc on vient même en
doutez nous même avoir douté de notre
propre santé alors que on le sait on a
des preuves on explique on continue
d'essayer d'éduquer autour de du racisme
système et et on se faisait manger
unités mais je ne vais pas faire une
guerre de sémantique
alors que la sémantique est primordial
puisque en droit en loi pour avoir une
justice dans le système politique un
système légal canadien il faut pouvoir
donner les mots exacts pour pouvoir se
défendre dans une cour de justice donc
on ne reconnaissant pas certains mots en
temps je ne veux pas nommer ces choses
là quand ils existent comme on fait pour
cent des fonds comment on fait pour
avoir justement la réconciliation comme
ça est il que pour les pensionnaires par
exemple il a fallu nommer les pensions
nous a fallu nommer justement la
problématique autour de ce système donc
on était encore à lutter pour faire en
temps nous voient encore à essayer de
faire entendre la voix de la raison mais
dans un concept que nous c'est une
question de survie et pour d'autres
c'est une question de responsabilité
mais dans cette année sur visite c'est
quand même un bon pendant des choses
positives justement les gens ont appris
à découvrir les aspects politiques mais
aussi l'aspect de leadership
traditionnel ça dure avec les oueds
souhaitait nous on a découvert que les
chefs de bande n'étaient pas les seuls
dirigeants qui existaient n'étaient pas
les seuls
lego au système politique qui existe
chez les communautés autochtones
donc cette discussion là pu aller de
l'avant on a pu y met de l'avant aussi
les problématiques les fragilités dans
les communautés qui encore en 2020
continue d'exister alors que feront pas
qu'on les reconnaît donc ça montre que
quand même un système à deux vitesses
pour les communautés et allochtones et
les communautés autochtones avec joyce
et chaque coin de malheureusement c'est
certain qu'en perdant une personne mais
de pouvoir enfin l'individualiser
contrairement à ce qui a été fait par le
passé par exemple avec les femmes
assassinées disparu ça change
complètement la manière d'avoir une
narration sur des enjeux difficile des
communautés autochtones d'enrouler une
femme autochtone qui est morte une femme
autochtone prostituée qui disparaît on à
joyce et chaque coin mère de famille qui
a une densité qu'une communauté derrière
et ont finalement on commence à
humaniser les personnes autochtones
quand des enjeux comme cela arrive dans
les communautés et pour finir bien je
pense que 2020 s'il ya une chose de
positif qui ressort c'est qu'on continue
d'en parler on continue de voir des
changements des fois petits dés fois
très grand mais l'amélioration vient à
celui qui continue de vouloir se
transformer et à mener une justice pour
des communautés vulnérables
je pense même juste des fois où
changement des noms des clubs sportifs
vous changement ou bien même au
collaboration qui existe en certaines
mouvances comme par exemple les
mouvances autochtone qui commencent à
travailler ensemble sur des enjeux qui
sont très différents selon de quelle
communauté tu viens mais qui ont un
fondement quand même assez similaire
donc ça permet de faire des nouvelles
solidarités entre les peuples non
j'espère que vous allez passer un beau
temps des fêtes
même si c'est cette année même si on a
envie une tradition nouvelle est pour
vous et pas justement des enjeux de
société
cependant on espère que 2021 va arriver
avec des bonnes nouvelles va arriver où
savez une relation renouvelée et encore
un désir d'aller de l'avant parce que je
pense que si je remarque une chose
depuis que je me suis mobilisé c'est une
transformation constante
et les gens ne peuvent plus ignorer les
enjeux d'injustice qui sont vécues par
d'autres
alors je fait une belle année je vous
espère pour 2021 et c'était pas partager
les vidéos et n'hésitez pas non plus à
nous envoyer vos questions pour
commentaires on les apprécie à chaque
fois